es ist ihr letzter großer Weg durch ihre
Stadt mitten durch London tausende
Menschen jetzt gerade auf den Straßen
und auch wir von Bild live natürlich
mittendrin bei der Prozession die Royals
begleiten die Queen die Familien
trauervereint das muss man mit einem
Fragezeichen versehen das werden wir uns
hier im Laufe der Sendung auch ganz
genau ansehen sehen Sie jetzt hier live
der Abschied von Königin Elizabeth II
wir Verstärkung im Studio freue mich
über es society-expertin Bettina von
Schimmelmann und unsere bild-show-chefin
darf nicht fehlen Tanja mai schön dass
ihr hier seid ihr zwei Tanja das ist ein
ganz großer Moment vor allem auch wenn
man an William und an Harry denkt denn
sie werden auch hinter dem Sarg der
jetzt in einer großen Prozession durch
die Stadt in London getragen wird
herlaufen und diese Bilder kennen wir
die kennen wir es ist schon etwas her
aber lasst uns gemeinsam einmal in diese
Bilder reinsehen diese beiden Jungs
damals waren sie 15 und 12 Jahre alt und
da sehen wir sie hinterherlaufen mit
Charles hinter dem Sarg in ihrer Mama
Diana und jetzt jetzt haben sie wieder
so einen Gang der sicherlich all diese
schmerzhaften Erinnerungen an damals an
das Jahr 1997 Tanja auch wieder auffühlt
in den beiden Prinzen ja Patricia
absolut also diese Bilder die wir jetzt
gleich sehen werden natürlich sehr in
ein absolut an die Beerdigung oder an
diesen Trauermarsch von Lady Diana
Prinzessin Diana die Kinder ich werde es
nie vergessen damals die Kinder hatten
ja einen Abschiedsbrief geschrieben Mami
stand drauf dann hatten sie oben auf den
Sack in die Blumen reingesteckt und
jetzt laufen eben 25 Jahre später beide
Prinzen mit Prinz Charles hinter dem
Sarg von Queen Elizabeth hair und man
ist automatisch 25 Jahre zurückversetzt
ja und man ahnt was jetzt in diesen
jungen Männern vorgeht natürlich werden
auch sie in Gedanken bei ihrer Mutter
sein aber ja auch die Trauer um die
geliebte Großmutter ist ja riesengroß
und auch die Trauer bei Prinz Charles
und seine Mutter jetzt der
sicherheitsschuldigung ich muss mich
immer noch daran gewöhnen die Trauer bei
King Charles den dritten natürlich auch
ist riesengroß und jetzt müssen sie eben
diesen Weg gehen und jeder Blick
natürlich diesen drei Männern jetzt ins
Gesicht und natürlich auch die große
Frage und das wollen wir uns jetzt hier
auch gleich genauer anschauen Bettina
glaubst du dass diese Trauer um die
Queen eine so wichtige Säule ein Kompass
auch für diese Familie eine ganz
bedeutende Figur des Zusammenhalts wird
die Trauer um die Queen diese Familie
und gerade die beiden Brüder wieder
einen also auf jeden Fall haben sie die
letzten Tage mehr miteinander gesprochen
als sie es wirklich seit gefühlt Jahren
gemacht haben und das ist eigentlich das
Schöne an der ganzen Sache dass wir sie
jetzt wieder zusammen sehen werden und
das ist auch etwas was die Queen auf
jeden Fall wollte also hätte man sie
gefragt und dann hat sie wahrscheinlich
gefragt wer soll denn dabei sein hat sie
bestimmt in einem Atemzug über die mit
Harry genannt und sie konnten sich
natürlich jetzt auch ein bisschen darauf
vorbereiten dazu kann man ja immer sagen
sie ist friedlich die Queen ist
friedlich eingeschlafen im Kreise zum
Teil ihrer Liebsten und sie dürfte auch
Einschlafen mit 96 und deswegen glaube
ich dass das auch ein irgendwo ein
Familienfest wird für alle eine Familie
es wird es kommt eine irrsinnige Familie
zusammen also ist mir weit mehr noch die
ganzen Cousins und Cousinen auch von
Prinz Philip noch also insofern ich
glaube die werden sich auch
untereinander sehr freuen sich zu sehen
zumindest sehen sie sich und zumindest
sind sie sich nah sie haben überhaupt
gar keine andere Möglichkeit schauen wir
uns einmal gemeinsam genauer an was da
heute jetzt in den nächsten Stunden
alles passieren wird gehen wir einmal
live nach London zu Julia wischewski
unserer Kollegin bildreporterin dort vor
Ort und auch Kira Ortmann dort
mittendrin bei Tausenden von Menschen
die sich jetzt dort in London versammelt
haben um ihre Queen bei dieser Reise
durch ihre Stadt zu begleiten Giulia
nimm uns einmal mit wir haben auch die
Route einmal vorbereitet was genau wird
jetzt in den nächsten Momenten passieren
ja also die Prozession wird jetzt bei
Buckingham Palace starten und dann ihren
Weg nehmen über white Hall auf Kurs
Westminster Hall wir befinden uns hier
in einem Pub nahe white Hall und man
sieht es ist proppenvoll und noch viel
mehr auf den Straßen hier direkt auf der
großen Meile white Holz zu Westminster
Hall wo in wenigen Minuten also in ca 38
Minuten am Ende der Prozession dann der
sagt der Queen eintreffen wird und für
vier Tage lang hier aufgebaut sein wird
damit die Öffentlichkeit auch Abschied
nehmen kann von der Queen also Julia du
hast dir auf jeden Fall hier sehen wir
noch mal die Route
genau 38 Minuten es ist natürlich
Schritt für Schritt alles durchgeplant
mit einem ganz ganz strengen Protokoll
wird diese Prozession dauern bis man
dann gegen 16 Uhr unserer Zeit in
Westminster Hall ankommt und wenn man
ganz auf die Uhr genau auf die Uhr
schaut in ca 15 Sekunden geht's los und
da ist man auch pünktlich aber Zeit
genug haben wir noch um einmal rüber zu
hüpfen zu Kira Ortmann auch sie vielen
herzlichen Dank Giulia für uns dort bei
den Menschen denen es an dem heutigen
Tag so wichtig ist ihrer Queen ein
letztes goodbye herüberzurufen
ganz genau und wir sind hier tatsächlich
nur wenige Meter von dem Buckingham
Palace entfernt wo es jetzt Patricia du
hast es gerade gesagt in wenigen
Sekunden losgehen wird und ich will euch
einfach einmal mitnehmen hier an den Ort
weil es haben sich und man sieht es ja
hier tausende zehntausende Menschen hier
an der Straße versammelt um dann noch
mal einen Blick eben auf diese
Prozession werfen zu können um sich
nochmal von der Queen und eben von bzw
von der Queen zu verabschieden und dann
auch eben dem Beistand an die royale
Familie spenden zu können und wir können
auch noch mal einmal hier die Straße
runter blicken denn tatsächlich ist es
so dass sich die Menschen in ungefähr
sind es hier so zehn rein pro Seite der
Straße aufgebaut haben und jetzt aber
auch schon seit einer Stunde hier
niemand mehr reinkommen darf es ist
tatsächlich sehr sehr gut hier
organisiert und jetzt wird mir hier
gerade gesagt dass wir hier auch ein
bisschen ruhiger sein sollen ganz genau
Kira denn während du sprichst wir haben
gesagt es geht ganz ganz pünktlich auf
die Sekunde los sehen wir hier die
Live-Bilder denn Prozession die verlässt
jetzt gerade den Buckingham Palace sehen
Sie jetzt gerade hier live aus London
die Bilder die Prozession die sich jetzt
in Bewegung setzt und dann genau 38
Minuten lang durch die Stadt ziehen wird
the mall hinunter diese Prachtstraße und
wir sehen das ganze natürlich begleitet
von Musik von Militär
die Pferde herausreiten es dauert ein
paar Sekunden und dann im Hintergrund
werden wir dann gleich den Sarg der
Queen auch sehen bei mir im Studio
Bettina von Schimmelmann und Tanja mai
lass uns gemeinsam einmal auf diesen
Bildern spazieren gehen denn man muss
sagen das sind historische Bilder Tanja
das sind Bilder wie wir sie alle noch
nie gesehen haben 70 Jahre saß Queen
Elizabeth auf dem Thron und jetzt jetzt
hat ihr Volk Gelegenheit Abschied zu
nehmen wer wird bei dieser Prozession
alles dabei sein die Kinder der Queen
werden auf jeden Fall dabei sein
Patricia und ich glaube wenn ich jetzt
aus der Ferne richtig sehe auf dem Pferd
Prinzessin die Tochter der Königin
reitet auf dem Pferd Prince Charles
ehemalige Prinz Charles König Charles
III und natürlich seine Söhne Harry und
William werden hinter dem Sarg der
Mutter und der Großmutter herlaufen der
Weg ist ja gar nicht so lange also ist
ein knapper Kilometer nur diese 38
Minuten aber man sieht ja also natürlich
wird dann sehr langsamen Tempo gelaufen
und damit ist auch wirklich das ganze
folgt die Möglichkeit hat einen Blick
auf den Sarg zu bekommen aber ich sehe
gerade en reitet nicht nein n läuft
hinter dem Sack hier sehen wir sie jetzt
alle die Kamera zieht gerade auf na auf
der linken Seite sehen wir King Charles
dann rechts neben ihm Prinzessin and sie
war eigentlich die ganze Zeit da in der
Stunde des Todes ihrer Mutter war sie da
und auch jetzt die ganze Zeit an der
Seite ja es ist bemerkenswert wie nah
sich die beiden Frauen doch standen also
Prinzessin Ellen wirkt auf mich sehr
sehr mitgenommen und heute wurde ja auch
bekannt dass sie diesen Satz gesagt hat
sie ist dankbar dass sie die letzten 24
Stunden bei ihrer Mutter sein durfte das
ist ja ein kleines Zeichen dass die
Queen scheinbar dann doch
im Bett lag wahrscheinlich also das
zumindest zwischen diesen Fotos die wir
erkennen dem Empfang der
Premierministerin und dem Tod der
Königin muss ja was passiert sein dass
es so so schnell ging aber Prinzessin an
war auf jeden Fall die letzten 24
Stunden an der Seite ihrer Mutter jetzt
hat man sich hier in Bewegung gesetzt
feierlich hat gerade eben den Buckingham
Palace verlassen
und jetzt wird man auch gleich sehen die
Menschen Massen die dort stehen dort der
Platz natürlich vor dem Buckingham
Palace weiträumig abgesperrt wir konnten
noch keinen genauen Blick auf William
und Harry erhaschen Bettina das sehen
wir bestimmt gleich für die Kamera
natürlich auch die Prinzen einmal zeigen
denn für sie auch darüber haben wir
gesprochen ist das natürlich ein Gang
der besonders schwer ist nicht nur
verabschieden sie ihre geliebte Granny
wie auch Harry an seiner offiziellen
Mitteilung ganz liebevoll gesagt hat
sondern dieser Zug dieses
hinterherlaufen hinter dem Sarg erinnert
die beiden Prinz natürlich schmerzlich
in den Verlust ihrer Mutter wir sind die
Krone
ich also ich habe auch gerade schon
Harry gesehen
William habe ich jetzt auch tatsächlich
noch nicht ausmachen können aber klar
für sie ist das ein eine formelle
Angelegenheit das ist keine
Verabschiedung in dem Sinne es ist
einfach auch ein Zeichen sie begleiten
ihre Granny durch das Volk also
buchstäblich durch das Volk und möchten
eben allen auch zeigen hier sie mir ein
bisschen ernähren Blick wer noch alles
dabei ist
es sind tatsächlich hauptsächlich außer
natürlich im männliche Mitglieder der
Familie die laufen das war wohl auch
schon bekannt dass eben Camilla Meghan
und Kate mit einem Auto hinterher fahren
das Auto konnten wir leider auch noch
nicht sehen aber man sieht ja auch den
Gleichschritt also dass das haben sie
das haben sie alle drauf an das kann man
sich sagen das haben sie natürlich
jahrelang auch zum Teil im Militär geübt
aber natürlich sie werden gerade William
und Harry die den Gang eben kennen und
die diese sargprozession mit dem
kanonenwagen kennen
ja die werden sich wahrscheinlich jetzt
einfach nur nach vorne konzentrieren und
hoffen dass das schnell vorbei ist
jetzt zieht man dort weiter wenige
Minuten hier sehen wir prachtvoll die
Krone auf dem Sarg der Queen dann auch
noch dekoriert mit weißen Blüten ihr
seid das sind weiße Rosen weiße Freesien
Rosmarin duftner rosmarin ist dabei von
Schloss belmaurel der schottischer
Landsitz auf dem sie vergangene Woche
verstorben ist
und da sehen wir auch wie in Edinburgh
absolute Stille und erbietung bei den
Menschen die dort seit Stunden seit den
frühen Morgenstunden stehen und warten
hier ist mal Einblick jetzt können wir
mal die Gesichter schauen dann sehen wir
Prinz Harry für ihn in haben wir so in
Erinnerung 12 Jahre war er ist Alter ist
er hinter dem Sarg von Diana Herr lief
und daneben sein Bruder Prinz William in
Uniform Prinzip ja keine Uniform da er
ja keinen Mitglied mehr ist der
arbeitenden Königsfamilie das war ja
sein Wunsch eben auszutreten aus der
Firma wie man das Königshaus ja wie die
sich selbst ja liebevoll nennen und er
ist ja mit seiner Frau nach Amerika
gezogen und ist das er ist heute dabei
aber er wird keine Uniform tragen also
das unseren Bruder nebenan hat man ja
gesehen trägt die Uniform und noch einen
haben wir ohne Uniform jetzt gerade kann
man ihn nicht sehen aber er fällt der
ersticht da natürlich sofort raus hier
können wir mal auf dem König ins Gesicht
schauen
Leben Prinzessin an
und Harry ohne Uniform obwohl er bei der
Army war aber eben er hat sich dazu
entschieden die königliche Familie zu
verlassen hier einen ganzen anderen
Blick mal auf den König und neben ihn
Prinzessin Ende die Trauer der
vergangenen Tage auch wirklich ins
Gesicht geschrieben steht und daneben
sehen wir den anderen Herren ohne
Uniformen können auf Prinz Andrew
Benziner und auch der aus guten Grund
ohne Uniform dort obwohl er im Vorland
war gedient hat aber auch er darf nicht
in Uniform kommen er darf nicht in
Uniform kommen ich habe auch gehört dass
Harry wohl trotzdem seine Uniform tragen
wollte und es ist hieß er soll das bitte
nicht tun heute weil es wieder für
verwirrungsstiften würde und ja Andrew
und Edward ist ja glaube ich auch dabei
aber
ein einfach ein trauriges Bild und
vielleicht aber auch ganz gut dass nicht
alle Uniform tragen muss ich jetzt ganz
persönlich sagen vielleicht wäre es ein
bisschen ich denke schon dass die alle
Uniform tragen wollten also habe ich auf
jeden Fall aber da hat der König ein
gesprochen wir gehen einmal mitten rein
wir sprechen mit Kira Ortmann denn jetzt
gerade Kira unsere Reporterinnen die
sich dort auch mitten in der
Menschenmenge tummelt und jetzt gerade
ist es bei dir so weit die Prozession
die kommt jetzt in diesen Kunden gleich
bei dir vorbei beschreibt uns einmal
diese Stimmung dort
[Musik]
ja ganz genau und ihr seht es hier die
Prozession ist jetzt gerade direkt
hinter mir
und die Menschen sind alle sehr sehr
ruhig hier und hören sich die Musik an
die hier gespielt wird
[Musik]
und wir Menschen ist es tatsächlich auch
ganz wichtig dass man hier eben die Ruhe
bewahrt wir haben gerade schon gesehen
dass manche Leute die hier irgendwie
noch geredet haben zum Beispiel auch
darauf aufmerksam gemacht wurden dass
Sie ihm bitte nicht mehr reden sollen
damit dieser Moment jetzt auch genossen
werden kann jetzt hier hinter mir geht
die Prozession los
[Musik]
absolute Stille jetzt auch gerade bei
dir Kira hier sehen wir noch mal die
Live-Aufnahmen der sagt der Queen
der dort
vorbeigezogen wird
eine Kutsche und man sieht die Menschen
die in absoluter Stille dort fachhachen
um ihrer Königin im letzten dank im
letzten News zu schicken genau 38
Minuten lang wird diese Prozession sein
am Ende dann in Westminster all das ist
das Ziel dass man konnte man anders geht
man gerade the mall entlang so ist diese
Prachtstraße mitten im Herzen von London
gerade eben den Buckingham Palace
verlassen und lass uns einmal hier im
Studio vielen Dank Kira für deine
Livebilder die wir hier gerade verfolgen
denn ich weiß es wurde um Stille gebeten
jetzt gerade das hast du uns gerade
geschildert deswegen wollen wir gar
nicht dass du weil sie dort negativ
auffällst die Menschen die dort sich
verabschieden wollen von ihrer Königin
und hinter dem Sack läuft natürlich King
Charles aber natürlich auch Prinzessin
an Prinz Andrew Prinz Edwards die Damen
haben wir nicht gesehen Prinzessin Andy
einzige Frau die Idee die wir dort sehen
was ist mit Camilla was ist mit Kate was
ist mit Meghan sehen wir die heute noch
die fest davon aus dass wir sie sehen
die Damen werden ja in einem Auto du
siehst hier die Menschen unterbrechen
die Menschen weinen viele verbeugen sich
auch vor der Königin Meghan Camilla die
neue Königs Gemahlin sie werden in einem
Auto hinterher gefahren hinter der
Prozession die konnten wir jetzt noch
nicht sehen denn natürlich ist heute
auch die große Frage wie einig ne die
Roy family sein in dieser Trauer hier
können wir auch mal Prinz William Prinz
Andrew und Prinzessin ins Gesicht
schauen
dort vorne hier
King Charles
und wir sehen auch Peter Philipps das
ist der Sohn von Prinzessin ann und hier
auch ohne Uniformen guter Blick auf
Prinz Andrej
[Musik]
miteinander laufen neben ihnen
das ist also die Reihe dann hinter den
beiden Prinzen wir hatten ein paar
Sekunden jetzt es ist nicht viel und man
ist natürlich dort eingebunden in ein
ganz ganz strenges Protokoll und dennoch
wollen wir hier im Studio natürlich
versuchen was können wir ablesen aus
diesem Gesichtern aus der Haltung jedes
Signal des Körpers schickt damit ja auch
eine Nachricht raus und haben uns
Unterstützung geholt Tilman Billing ist
hier bei uns jetzt Experte für
Körpersprache und auch Gründer der
digitalen Lernplattformen Stage
rocker.de und rockt jetzt unsere stage
hier hat ganz genau hier die Royal
Family beobachtet und ich habe gerade
schon gesagt Herr Billing natürlich sind
die mit dem Blick nach vorne gerichtet
haben nicht viel Spielraum für ihren
Körper und genau da brauchen wir Ihre
Hilfe denn oft sind es ja die kleinen
Signale die Blicke in den Augen die
Haltung des Körpers
wenn man herauslesen kann wie ist
eigentlich das Verhältnis beispielsweise
zwischen William und Harry die ein
schweren Gang jetzt dort haben die sich
mit Sicherheit auch erinnert fühlen an
die Beerdigung ihrer Mutter Diana was
konnten sie aus diesen ganz kurzen
Momenten herauslesen im Momenten indem
wir da einen Blick auf die beiden Aschen
konnten
also sie beide sind ja im großen Korsett
also das ist alles formal festgelegt sie
müssen eine starren Blick haben sie
haben auch sowas militärisches und da
ist wenig Platz für Emotionen für
Empathie auch aber ich glaube das ist
für Harry sehr günstig weil wir haben ja
am Samstag diesen Auftritt gehabt der
vier der beiden Paare und da hat man
gespürt wie unwohl sich auch Harry
gefühlt hat und wie er kein Blickkontakt
mit seinem Bruder haben wollte also
William war ja da Brückenbauer und
Versöhner das war seine Rolle er hat
versucht immer wieder Kontakt mit Harry
aufzunehmen und Harry hat ganz stur
gerade ausgeguckt und hat keinen
Blickkontakt aufgenommen und es kommt
ihm jetzt natürlich zu Pass jetzt kann
er das wieder tun stur geradeaus schauen
sein Bruder gar nicht wahrnehmen ohne
dass das negativ auffällt und es war am
Samstag beim Rundgang vor Schloss
Windsor als die Prinzen sich die Blumen
angeschaut haben natürlich ganz anders
aber jetzt ist er eine Rolle wo er diese
Kluft die gegen den Brüdern herrscht
auch diese Eiseskälte die da ist die
kann praktisch jetzt
da kann er praktisch kein praktisch
existieren ohne dass es negativ auffällt
und es war am Samstag komplett anders
also jetzt geht ihm das fast so einen
Rahmen sagen sie ne dass er sich nicht
auseinandersetzen muss wie er auf seinen
Bruder jetzt gerade konnten wir die auch
noch mal ganz kurz sehen wir schauen
auch immer dass wir die
Kameraeinstellungen der verschiedenen
Kameras dort erwischen wo wir dort
wirklich mal nah ran kommen jetzt hat
man einmal einen guten Blick auf den
Sack dort die Krone von Queen Elizabeth
und auch wunderschöne Blüten weiße
Blüten weiße Freesien weiße Rosen aber
auch durfende Kräuter dort aus dem
Garten von Schloss belmoral wo sie
vergangene Woche verstorben ist hier
sieht man ein bisschen Hinterkopf noch
von den Royals aber natürlich wollen wir
ja denen auch ins Gesicht schauen denn
die ganze Welt fragt sich was ist mit
diesen beiden Brüdern können Sie sehen
dass es für sie ein schwerer Gang ist
kann man herauslesen aus dem Gang der
beiden Brüder und der ist ja selbst
vorgegeben Tempo angepasst jeder Schritt
ist ja koordiniert und abgesprochen also
wahrscheinlich auch da sehr sehr wenig
Freiraum aber erkennt man manchmal im
Körper dass das eine besondere Schwere
hat können Sie da etwas rauslesen bei
William und Harry die wir so vor Augen
haben mit 15 und 12 Jahren mit ihren
gesenkten Köpfen wie sie hinter dem Sarg
von Diana herlaufen
en genau so wie sie das Ansprechen ich
denke da werden diese Gedanken auch
wieder kommen der Tod ihrer Mutter und
jetzt auch die Großmutter zu der sie
emotional ja beide auch ein sehr
intensives Verhältnis hatten gerade
Harry der so ein bisschen der verstoßene
Sohn war und trotzdem dieses innige
Verhältnis zu seiner Oma hatte und ich
denke das sieht man teilweise an den
Gesichtszügen dass sie wirklich auch
versuchen die zu beherrschen und auch zu
bleiben in diesem militärischen
in dieser Haltung die sie haben das ja
auch diese Emotionen die durchaus da
sind nicht wirklich sichtbar sind und
das ist durchaus sichtbar dass sie immer
wieder versuchen ihre Mimik auch
entsprechend zu kontrollieren um eben in
dem Moment gerade keine Emotionen auch
zu zeigen und auch vor allem das was
zwischen ihnen auch da ist wirklich
jetzt unter den Teppich zu kehren und
nicht nach außen sichtbar werden zu
lassen ich finde hier sieht man jetzt
gerade Harry ganz gut
ich weiß nicht ob es einfach seine
Körperhaltung ist aber er schlendert
fast so ein bisschen es sieht fast so
aus ich könnte herein interpretieren
dass er sich vielleicht trotz des
tragischen traurigen und sehr formellen
Anlasses vielleicht doch auch so eine
innerliche Lässigkeit und Abstand zur
Royal Family antrainiert hat denn
normalerweise ist er ja ganz weit weg in
einem ganz anderen Leben irgendwo in
Kalifornien mit einem Stall voller
Hühner und wenig Paparazzi so hofft er
die ihm da folgen also für ihn ist es ja
wie so ein Besuch wie so ein reinhüpfen
in eine völlig andere Welt Tanja
schüttelt wild mit dem Kopf aber einmal
hole ich sie ab und dann kannst du
sofort wieder sprechen Tanja genau das
hat man am Samstag ja schon gesehen dass
auch Harry und Meghan sehr viel lockerer
waren auch sehr viel mehr Körperkontakt
gezeigt haben Zärtlichkeiten
ausgetauscht haben werden William und
Kate sehr steif waren und sich gar nicht
berührt haben ja auch komplikontakt
hatten und da war Harry sehr viel
lässiger Meghan auch und das sieht man
jetzt auch wieder also man sieht dass er
hat ja offiziell auch darauf ver findet
praktisch diese königlichen
Privilegien zu haben und das sieht man
jetzt aber auch im Körper dass er ein
bisschen befreiter ist dass er lockerer
ist und dass er auch lässiger und
eleganter und natürlich auch natürlicher
ist und nicht so steif sie hat sich auch
in dem bekannten Interview mit
beklagt dass er und auch sein Vater nee
das sein Vater und William sein Bruder
dass die so sehr in den Konventionen
gefangen sein dass er dass
hat er nicht also er ist freier und das
sieht man auch an seine Körpersprache du
hast trotzdem wild mit den Kopf
geschüttelt wir wollen uns gleich wir
haben nur ein paar Sekunden weil wir
wollen gleich mal hier wirklich in die
Menschenmenge gehen zu meiner Kollegin
Kira Ortmann aber sag mal du empfindest
das anders du glaubst dass das für Harry
nicht einfach ist ich glaube dass Prinz
Harry heute sehr leidet dass er eben
nicht diese insign der des Königshauses
tragen kann er wollte ja unbedingt
Uniform tragen der König hat dann
Machtwort gesprochen er ist kein
Mitglied mehr da arbeitenden Royals
deswegen wird er keine Uniform tragen
ich glaube er hätte sie gerne angehabt
und ich glaube auch was
ähm was am Freitagabend dieses
herausgehen aus dem Schloss er und
Meghan die halten ja immer Händchen also
man hat das Gefühl sie krallt sich ja
immer so an ihn bzw er krallt sich an
sie und natürlich war das schon auch
gerade bei Meghan sie genießt diesen
Auftritt natürlich sie genießt es und
sie wollen natürlich nach außen zeigen
wir sind ein Team uns geht's besser als
allen anderen ich glaube aber nicht dass
es ihnen besser geht und ich glaube auch
nicht dass sie die glücklichen Menschen
sind in diesem königlichen das ist eine
ganz ganz große Frage ne wer ist
glücklich die die eingebunden sind in
diesen starren Traditionen oder hier
können wir jetzt mal Harry wirklich ins
Gesicht sehen lassen wir mal diese
Bilder auch auf uns wirken jetzt konnte
man ihn wirklich mal frontal ins Gesicht
schauen darüber sprechen wir gleich aber
wir wollen einmal richtig eintauchen
wollen zu den Menschen die dort seit
Stunden ausharren wunderschöner Blick
auf die Krone von Queen Elizabeth gehen
wir rüber zu Kira Ortmann denn dort Kira
bei dir wir sehen hier weiterhin die
Live-Bilder aber bei dir warteten die
Menschen
stundenlang um diese einen Blick zu
bekommen und du kannst uns schildern
dass die Emotionen ganz viele Menschen
um dich herum jetzt eben in diesem
Moment so richtig gepackt haben
absolut wir haben hier tatsächlich mit
vielen Menschen im Laufe des Tages
gesprochen die teilweise schon um 4 Uhr
morgens hierher gekommen sind um eben
einen Platz in der ersten Reihe zu
bekommen unter eine von denen war Sarah
sarah ist hier bei mir sie hat hier
gesessen gerade während der Prozession
and Sarah your quite you cried i so you
crying when they a passing bei
ich finde
Katalogs and
so sie sagte gerade eben es ist eben ein
ganz ganz besonderer Moment für sie
gewesen hier und einen eher special
moment und ich glaube besser kann man es
eben gar nicht beschreiben und ich würde
sie jetzt auch noch mal fragen wie Sie
Harry und William dort eben gerade
erlebt hat wenn ihr Soul Prince William
and Prince Harry wood wills because the
last time Resort them behind coffin like
this I was when Diana die
lost really that the Griffin der
grandmaul
and sadness and maybe this is a time for
family Street night and we build on
noch mal einmal sie hat jetzt gerade
gesagt dass sie eben sich auch wünscht
dass Prinz William und Prinz Harry jetzt
auch wieder mehr zueinander finden eben
gerade das was ihr jetzt ja auch im
Studio noch mal betont habt dass
eventuell das ja auch der Wunsch war der
Queen die ja ebenso für im auf Frieden
und Einheit stand dass die beiden wieder
zueinander finden und jetzt möchte
trotzdem noch einmal fragen so alter you
crying and all the people where so
Emotion hier today why is it so
important for you to be here and ja weil
the feeling so strong wurde Queen the
Queen service
and for me personally she so woman
höchstens soll strong soll konstant in a
world very much and men's world sei für
mich am hapeter
I am very disappointe that we love a
wonderful Queen eine string to woman and
someone you is helps in power me in my
life and
mother heißt now gone
sie hat gerade auch noch mal gesagt und
das war tatsächlich auch das was wir
hier von vielen Menschen vor Ort gehört
haben sie war wie eine Großmutter für
die Menschen und deswegen sind die
Menschen hier auch so emotional dass die
Queen jetzt eben gestorben ist und hier
auf ihrem letzten Weg in die Westminster
Hall gerade begleiten konnten Kira
vielen herzlichen Dank emotionale
Einblicke sie war für uns alle wie eine
Großmutter ich glaube das beschreibt das
Gefühl ganz gut dass viele Menschen
haben die jetzt auch zu Tausenden
dorthin geströmt sind um die Queen zu
begleiten auf dieser letzten Reise
schauen wir live in diese Bilder herein
es ist eine große Stille dort eine große
Andacht dort in diesen Sekunden während
die Queen durch ihre Stadt reißt durch
ihr London reist the mall ging es jeden
Montag 38 Minuten wird diese Prozession
dauern dann das Ziel Westminster Hall
und auch dort haben dann die Menschen
noch vier Tage lang die Gelegenheit sich
zu verabschieden bevor am Montag die
große Beerdigung das große Staats
Begräbnis Tanja Volz wie werden die
nächsten Tage aussehen was glaubst du
was bedeutet das auch für diese Familie
meinst du die haben zwischendrin auch
mal Zeit miteinander zu reden zur Ruhe
zu kommen sieht es bei King Charles der
Jagd muss man sagen in dieser schweren
Zeit auch für ihn ein Termin in den
nächsten
ja er hatte eigentlich nur die Nacht des
Todes seiner Mutter also dieser erste
Nacht von Donnerstag auf Freitag da war
die Familie vereint im Schloss in
Schottland und ab dem nächsten Morgen ab
Freitag weil er er war ja der neue König
und er musste natürlich auch
funktionieren als der neue König er
musste aber trotzdem auch irgendwie
seine Trauer ja verarbeiten und ich
glaube das ist extrem schwierig wenn die
ganze Welt auf dich blickt und du
draußen deine Mutter du musst aber auch
jetzt der neue König sein ich möchte
noch einen Hinweis geben zu Prinz Harry
ist mir jetzt aufgefallen er trägt ja zu
Ehren seiner Großmutter auch Abzeichen
also er trägt die Orden zum 50 60 und 70
drohnjubiläum auch das ein Zeichen an
seine geliebte Großmutter und hier
kommen jetzt die Autos mit Kate und
Camilla und wohl auch Meghan
schauen wir mal es ist nämlich offiziell
nicht bekannt ob Meghan in diesen
offiziellen Ablauf in irgendeiner Form
eingebunden ist oder Tanja es ist
bekannt dass sie mitfahren wird ich will
jetzt nur gespannt ich sehe es jetzt
leider auch nicht auf die Entfernung
ich vermute dass Meghan in einem anderen
Auto sitzt das wird auch so viel die
Frau von Prinz Edward also die
Schwiegertochter der Königin sie wird
auch in einem der Autos sitzen aber
allein diese Konstellation zu sehen aber
es ist natürlich klar dass Camilla und
Kate also die Gemahlin des Königs und
die Gemahlin des nächsten Königs dass
die beiden sind ja die ranghöchsten
Damen im Palast das die beiden Damen
natürlich zusammen im Auto fahren ist
klar ich wüsste auch gerne ob Prinz
George z.B dabei ist also der älteste
Sohn von William und Kate er ist ja dann
der übernächste Thronfolger also all das
würde ich jetzt gerne sehen aber leider
sind die Autos jetzt schon wieder weg es
eben gerade konnten wir auch gut noch
einmal in die Gesichter schauen Herr
Billinger konnten Sie ablesen bei wem
die Trauer am meisten
das sind ja Gesichter die müssen sich
zusammenreißen die können dieser Trauer
keinen freien Lauf lassen das Protokoll
lässt das gar nicht zu und auch die
Tränen die wir vielleicht als menschlich
empfinden würden werden dort
vermutlicher als fehl am Platz empfunden
können Sie die Trauer ablesen aus den
Gesichtern oder haben die Royals quasi
schon so viel Training so viel Disziplin
dass sie eine Art Maske aufsetzen in
einer so schwierigen Situation also bei
den fernsehbilden ist natürlich jetzt
schwierig weil wir wenig Nahaufnahmen
hatten aber bei Harry sieht man diese
Zerrissenheit die er sicher hat er
möchte noch dazu gehören auf der einen
Seite so wie sie gesagt haben er möchte
die Uniform haben er ist ja auch ein
sehr begeisterter Flieger gewesen bei
der Air Force und so das ist schon auch
ein Teil seines Lebens aber er hat auch
das neue Leben er steht auch zu melden
er steht zu der USA steht zu der zu der
freien Welt das heißt er ist genau
dazwischen und Sitz Zerrissenheit hat
man gesehen und jetzt wird man vor allem
denke ich bei der Migräne sehen wie es
aussieht mit der Trauer dann werden wir
auch die Gesichter näher sehen können
und dann werden wir sehen wer genau noch
in dieser Rolle ist auch in dieser
Steifheit ist auch in diesem Korsett ist
und wer echte Emotionen echte
Menschlichkeit und auch echte Empathie
zulässt und es auch sichtbar werden
lässt das ist ja auch eine spannende
Frage das ist ja auch wie eine Art
Modernisierung in der Monarchie Tanja
oder dass man da Emotionen zulässt du
verfolgst gerade auch mit Spannung die
Gesichter in die wir da mich berühren
diese Bilder mich haben auch die Bilder
letzte Woche berührt als die Königin
gestorben ist und nicht den König zum
ersten Mal gesehen habe den man ja die
Trauer angesehen hat auch Camilla also
die sind ja um Jahre gealtert das sieht
man und ich glaube dass die sich auch
erlauben Tränen fließen zu lassen also
ich habe noch die Beerdigung von Prinz
Philip sie war ja letztes Jahr im April
der Ehemann der Königin ist gestorben
und auch da saß damals noch Prinz
Charles jetzt König Charles III und da
sind Tränen geflossen und ich bin sicher
dass auch bei der Beerdigung am Montag
Tränen fließen werden und das ist also
durchaus auch im Königshaus erlaubt wenn
man hier Prinz Harry noch mal sieht auch
interessant der feiert ja morgen sein 38
Geburtstag und also jetzt einerseits der
Abschied der geliebten Großmutter dann
der Geburtstag also das sind Millionen
von Emotionen die jetzt bei dieser
ganzen Familie verarbeitet werden müssen
Bettina ist wieder bei uns Bettina von
Schimmelmann wir machen hier im Studio
während wir diese Prozession live hier
bei verfolgen immer mal wieder einen
fliegenden Wechsel wir wollen auch
gleich wieder Tillmann binding zu uns
holen Körpersprache Experte der ganz
genau jetzt währenddessen hier hinter
den Kulissen den drys in die Augen
schaut in die Gesichter schaut Bettina
dass uns einmal heute den Ablauf
durchgehen man marschiert jetzt dort was
ist danach noch alles geplant
also es ist tatsächlich alles
Generalstabs mäßig organisiert und das
ist das was Tanja eingangs auch als the
firm beschrieb seit Tagen beschäftigt
sich ein ganz riesiges Team zusammen
auch mit den Medienunternehmen vor Ort
wie machen wir das alles wann wo geht's
los wo geht es hin wer läuft es gab ja
sogar eine Probe genau von dieser
Prozession und wir haben auch gerade
eben über die die Autos gesprochen ich
bin ja fest davon überzeugt dass auch
die PR-Leute sie auch gibt einen ganzen
Stab von Buckingham Palace genau
entschieden haben wer fährt mit wem im
Auto weil es soll auf gar keinen Fall
heute darum gehen um Schlagzeilen Kate
und Meghan wiedervereint dass das das
glaube ich Bettina dass wir Unterbrecher
aber es ist natürlich das Protokoll also
heute bestimmt das Protokoll keine
PR-Firma und Camilla ist natürlich die
ranghöchste Dame dann kommt Kate also
die beiden sitzen zusammen im Auto
Meghan ist ja eigentlich unwichtig also
sie hat keine offizielle Funktion mehr
sie gehört nicht offiziell zum
Königshaus dass sie da überhaupt dabei
sein darf das ist ja überhaupt schon der
größte Ritterschlag den man hier
zukommen lassen kann aber sie einfach
keine Rolle deswegen sie wird dabei sein
aber sie wird in einem hinteren Wagen
fahren aber sicherlich versuchen ob es
jetzt PR oder Protokoll Verlass
Mitarbeiter zu verhindern dass das
Augenmerk wegkommt von der Queen und von
diesem wichtigen und andächtigen Moment
dass man ganz klar hier diesen Abschied
im Zentrum hat und natürlich nicht auch
wenn ich gebe das zu uns das hier
natürlich im Studio auch Spaß macht weil
darüber zu reden was ist mit der Megan
wie vertragen sie sich aber das Anliegen
klar das Palastes ist es wir wollen
heute von unserer Königin Abschied
nehmen hier sehen wir die Live-Bilder
jetzt geht es hier einmal durch schauen
wir einmal auf die Uhr 38 Minuten dauert
das ganze um Punkt 16 Uhr soll man dann
ankommenden Westminster Hall und meine
Kollegin Julia wischewski die hat sich
in ein Pub gemischt und zwar nicht weil
sie sich da gemütlich macht sondern weil
sich dort natürlich viele Menschen auch
treffen und von oben einen Blick auf das
zu haben was dort unten auf der Straße
passiert wir waren jetzt mit meiner
Kollegin Julia sprechen die das sind die
Live-Bilder von Julia gefilmt eben ein
bisschen weiter oben aus dem Pub denn
jetzt in diesen Sekunden da zieht die
Prozession Giulia bei dir dort vorbei
wie kannst du diese Stimmung beschreiben
wir haben gesehen es kann ganz schnell
vielleicht sogar auch in einem Pub ganz
ganz leise werden wenn ein so bewegender
Moment passiert
ja also vor wenigen Minuten wurde ich
hier noch gechiert und auf den Namen der
Queen ein Glas erhoben zu ihren Ehren
und jetzt ist es mucksmäuschen still
hier im Pub auf white Hall auf der
Zielgeraden zu westminsterhol wo sie
dann aufgebahrt werden wird und man muss
sagen es ist fast schon gespenstte bzw
symbolisch weil im Moment kommt gerade
die Sonne raus es war den ganzen Tag
total niedlich und ja düster wolkig kalt
und jetzt scheint die Sonne es ist fast
als würde Queen Elizabeth II noch einmal
mit ihrer positiven Energie ihrem Licht
hier Tschüss sagen zu ihrem Volk und die
Menschen sind hier in Massen am
Straßenrand deswegen wir haben von oben
hier den Topf Blick auf die Prozession
und sehen wie die sich jetzt Richtung
Westminster Hall auf white Hall of
dieser Meile bewegt und hier
voranschreitet
und eine Dame meinte auch gerade im
Hintergrund es sei sehr respektvoll und
ich glaube das ist ja auch dieses
Attribut was man mit der Queen
respektvoll würdig das ist ja wirklich
ja dieses Hauptattribut der Queen und
das wird hier auch noch mal deutlich bei
der Prozession
man hört doch noch ein bisschen
stimmende Gewirr bei dir im Hintergrund
wir haben eben gerade Giulia mit Kira
gesprochen und dort waren manche
Menschen in Tränen aufgelöst vor Rührung
da haben wir gehört das ist wie unsere
Großmutter ich bin geboren da war die
Queen schon da und sie war für mich
immer da was schönen dir die Menschen
die jetzt in diesem Pub den Abschied
diese letzte große Reise durch London
hier sehen wir noch mal die Bilder live
der Queen vom Pub aus verfolgen
[Musik]
na Julia glaube ich die Verbindung ist
gerade abgebrochen wir sprechen gleich
wieder jetzt haben wir hier gerade mal
einen Blick gehabt auf Prinz Ellen Joe
wir haben das eingangs gesagt auch der
fällt natürlich auf denn auch der keine
uniforme an und das ist ein untypisches
Bild in dieser Prozession Bettina Prinz
Andrew ja eigentlich früher ein
Lieblingssohn sobald er immer ne von der
Queen bis er erst zu Randy Andy wurde
und bis er dann ganz ganz schlimme
Verwicklungen hatte in einen
Missbrauchskandal und schließlich
geschafft wurde für eine Royal Family
hier sind wir Prinz Harry auch noch mal
absolut er ist in Ungnade gefallen und
das wäre auch etwas was ihm das Volk
natürlich nicht verziehen hätte wenn er
jetzt heute wieder stolz die Uniform
angezogen hätte also das war der Queen
immer schon sehr wichtig sie hat sich
immer zwar vor ihre Familie gestellt
aber sie wusste auch sie ist wie das
Volk da und sie ist für also sie muss
auch Zeichen setzen und sie hat auch
damals schon ganz klar E-Mail alle
offiziellen Aufgaben entzogen man muss
ja wirklich sagen es sind richtig
Aufgaben die sonst stattfinden also
Princess also n hat ja ich glaube über
370 Termine im Jahr also das kriegt man
oftmals nicht mit und das sind dann so
die ganz Kleinen Termine auch mal hier
eine Einweihung da ein Auftritt da ist
wieder etwas wo eine
Wohltätigkeitsveranstaltung also die
sind immer sehr sehr sehr sie war super
oder ist super fleißig und
deswegen ist es auch so schön sie jetzt
so nah an der Queen dran zu sehen wenn
man wirklich sagen muss sie hat eine
ganz ganz ganz besondere Verbindung die
zwei und Andrew ja für ihn ist das ein
Spießrutenlauf heute glaube ich das ist
etwas was ihm überhaupt nicht liegt wo
er am liebsten sagen würde das muss das
sein aber es muss Fergie seine extra
dafür nicht kommen ne weil die beiden
geschieden sind also da ist man wirklich
noch sehr ich formuliere es mal so
oldschool was das betrifft obwohl sie ja
sonst auch noch enge Verbindungen zur
Familie hat auch ihre Töchter Beatrice
und Genie beide sind ja heute dann dabei
jetzt haben wir noch fünf Minuten dann
wird man da antreffen in westmin hall
was wird dort alles passieren wer ist
dort alles dabei ganz groß ist die
Familie wirklich extended family heißt
es ja so schön Tanja ne ja wenn jetzt
gleich im Parlament eingetroffen wird
dann wird ja der königliche Sarg wird ja
dann aufgebaut auf einer Stafette das
ist ein ganz eindrucksvolles Bild was
wir da jetzt gleich sehen werden und da
werden ja bestimmte Soldaten auch Wache
halten also immer alle sechs Stunden
wird dann auch gewechselt und es geht ja
bis Montag früh um 6:30 Uhr und das wird
natürlich auch gemacht damit das Volk
jetzt von seiner Königin Abschied nehmen
kann man konnte sich ja registrieren
seit dem Todestag und das geht auch ganz
klar nach Fahrplan das wirklich
Millionen Menschen die Chance haben am
sagt der Königin vorbei zu definieren
und sich zu verabschieden schon jetzt
befürchtet man ja dass man da teilweise
20 30 40 Stunden anstehen wird ne um
überhaupt ein Blick zu bekommen auf den
Sarg in Westminster Hall also da braucht
man ganz schön Geduld aber wir waren in
Edinburgh gesehen die Geduld bringen die
Menschen auf die Royal Fans die ein
letztes goodbye ihrer Königin eine
letzte Ehre erweisen wollen lassen sich
nicht abhalten von den langen langen
Wartezeiten dort schauen wir noch mal
einmal in die Live-Bilder vier Minuten
noch geht es ganz genauso alles ganz
genau getimt nach strengen Protokoll
haben wir hier von oben einen Blick auf
den Sack der Queen vier Tage lang wird
er dort aufgebaut sein ja bis Montag
früh um 6:30 Uhr hat das Volk ihm die
Möglichkeit sich von seiner Königin zu
verabschieden
und glaubt ihr denn Bettina dass wir
jetzt wenn die Prozessionen gleich auch
ankommt meint ihr dass wir da einen
Blick bekommen auch auf die Damen wir
wollen Queen concerts ja wir wollen
Camilla natürlich sehen wir wollen auch
einmal Kate sehen und wir sind natürlich
wenn sie jetzt immer noch nicht gesehen
sie soll im Auto sitzen aber wir haben
sie noch nicht gesehen wir wollen
natürlich auch einen Blick auf Meghan
einmal werfen glaubt ihr es wird die
Gelegenheit gleich in wenigen Minuten
dreieinhalb ich schau auf die Uhr sind
es ganz genau noch es wird sich die
Gelegenheit bieten dass wir die Frauen
aus der Royal Family ob offizielles
Mitglied oder nicht mehr gleich mal
sehen werden also
ich geografisch kann ich jetzt nicht
ganz genau sagen wo sie anhalten werden
aber ich glaube eben tatsächlich auch
dass das kommt jetzt wieder meine
pr-taktik dass ich sage sie wollen es
einfach doch zeigen dass alle dabei sind
und wollen es nicht bei diesen Bildern
im Auto belassen also da spricht man
sich doch sowohl im Palast eben auch mit
dem Pressevertretern ab dass man sagt
also das und das machen wir und dann
wissen wir auch alle genau was auf sie
zukommt deswegen ich hoffe und ich
glaube dass die Damen so aus den Autos
steigen dass wir sie sehen können das
hoffen wir dass wir dir gleich sehen das
ist eine riesige Prozession muss man
sagen die jetzt dann gleich ankommt in
Westminster Hall sie sehen hier die Life
Guides in Blues in Royal units of the
house hold cavalary und die Haushalte
Vision foot guards and puckingham
balance waren dabei auch Mitglieder
quasi das Haushalts des Königs und der
Königin dürfen dort mitlaufen was für
eine r-abbietung auch an all die die
sich jahrzehntelang darum gekümmert
haben alles zusammenzuhalten die ganz
nah waren bei der Queen
ja das zeigt eben auch wie verbunden die
Königin nicht nur mit ihrem Volk war mit
ihrer Familie sondern auch eben mit
ihren Angestellten und das ist natürlich
jetzt auch der letzte Respekt und auch
das letzte Dankeschön was man eben
diesen Menschen geben darf
Salutschüsse jetzt
zu Ehren der Queen lassen wir uns auch
weil diese Bilder auf uns wirken jetzt
hier auch dieser Blick auf den Sarg von
Queen Elizabeth auf
die Blumen auf die Krone auf ihrem Sarg
wie Sie sehen und hört sie Musik dort
und man hat der Straße von den Tausenden
Menschen dass wir das mal auf uns wirken
hört man fast gar nichts
absolute Stille
[Musik]
und hier und da pflanzt eben der
applausen Applaus des Respekts hoch
für ihre Queen die jetzt unter dem
Applaus ihres Volks
dort ihre letzte Reise da sind wir mal
auch eine Gesichter der Menschen
der letzte Reise antritt
als gleich sehen wir das
glockengeläutchen findet diese Reise
auch ein Ende dort in Westminster Hall
gesagt wird begleitet von Charles von
William von Harry Prinzessin an Prinz
Andrew natürlich dabei wir sehen wir ihn
der einzige ohne Uniform und neben ihnen
Prinz Edward sein Bruder und dahinter
eine gerade noch gesehen ein bisschen
was von Harry von Prinz William und auch
Peter Philipps der Cousin der beiden der
Sohn von Prinzessin Anne
offiziell sollte ja König Charles immer
einen Schritt vorauslaufen ich glaube
das ist bei der Länge jetzt nicht mehr
immer ganz so einfach aber ich sehe dass
die Geschwister doch immer versuchen
zumindest einen halben Schritt dahinter
zu gehen ab und zu sind ja doch in einer
Reihe und auch das finde ich ein schönes
Zeichen das von wegen wir sind hier zu
viert vereint und wir laufen jetzt hier
zu viert und dann kann das Protokoll mal
auch ein ein Schritt außer Acht gelassen
werden und jetzt sieht man jetzt biegt
man dort ein und da ist natürlich
weiträumig abgesperrt wir nehmen ja an
auch Bettina dass die Autos vielleicht
dann dort auch Vorfahren werden
man wird sich da jetzt rein begeben es
ist noch mal 20 Minuten ein Gottesdienst
eine kurze Andacht geplant
und ich glaube eben dass auch da in
diesem Hof selber dass da tatsächlich
natürlich auch Kameras sind das ist
alles so bestückt und
es ist einfach jetzt so ein schönes Bild
zu sehen und auch der Applaus war so
schön zu hören einfach den gab es
natürlich wir haben eingangs über
Princess Dianas Beerdigung oder
Prozession gesprochen den gab es damals
natürlich nicht das war halt damals der
Schock war zu groß und es gab gar kein
Anlass des das Klatschens heute ist
dieser Applaus eine Respekt und auch ein
vielen Dank dass wir heute an diesem Tag
dabei sein dürfen ich glaube das soll
wirklich einfach Danke ausdrücken wir
fragen für die Lebensleistung der
Königin also ich denke diana hat ja in
dem Sinn
nichts geleistet aber die Königin
natürlich 70 Jahre hat sie wirklich
ihrem Volk gedient
jetzt sehen wir es hat man
das Ziel dieser Prozession erreicht
jetzt geht es rein der Sarg wird
reingetragen wo in Westminster Hall
fast 1000 Jahre alt dieses Gebäude
und so nimmt die letzte große Reise der
Queen hier zumindest vorerst ihr Ende
die letzte große Reise durch ihre Stadt
durch London heraus aus dem Buckingham
Palace hat sie ihren Weg gemacht unter
dem Balkon hindurch wo wir sie so oft
gesehen sagen so viele Gelegenheiten
Geburtstag gefeiert shooting the color
Hochzeiten schöne Anlässe schwieriger
Anlässe für die Queen und von dort hat
sie jetzt und es sehen Sie hier jetzt
gerade bei Wildlife ihre letzte große
Reise durch ihre Stadt angetreten wir
haben das Glockengeläuts
jetzt in wenigen Sekunden
diese Reise jetzt vorerst ihr Ende
gefunden und zwar in der Westminster
Hall fast 1000 Jahre altes Gebäude und
dort geht es jetzt rein hier noch einmal
ein Blick auf die Royal Family
wir sehen ganz links King Charles Rezept
daneben auch in Uniform Prinzessin an
dann sehen sie Prinz Harry und Prinz
Edward die beiden einzigen doorte Royal
Family des engen Kreises die ohne
Uniform dort sind und am Rand dann Prinz
Edward und dahinter sehen wir dann auch
noch entsorgen Peter Philipps ernsmann
searchem Lawrence ist dabei der Duke of
gluter Earl of Snowden also der ganz
ganz enge Kreis der Familie
das war die letzte große Reise von
Königin Elisabeth der zweiten 70 Jahre
auf dem Thron 96 Jahre leben
die meisten die uns jetzt sicherlich
auch hier zuschauen kennen es gar nicht
anders ohne die Queen
viele gewöhnen sich noch dass man nicht
mehr Prinz Charles sagt sondern King
Charles the third wir sehen ihn hier
hinten links stehen hinter dem Sarg
seiner Geliebten Mami wie er sagt der
sagte jetzt hineingebracht wird
ein zu Westminster Hall vier Tage lang
haben die Britinnen und Briten jetzt
Gelegenheit dort ihrer Königin ihrer
Queen ein letztes goodbye zu sagen
am Montag dann das große Staatsbegräbnis
alle europäischen Adelshäuser selbst das
japanische Kaiserpaar wird anwesend sein
zu diesem Staatsbegräbnis auch das sehen
Sie natürlich dann hier bei Bild live
wir hören noch einmal um diese letzten
Sekunden hineinlassen ist noch mal auf
uns wirken die letzte Reise der Queen
durch London die hier zu einem Ende
kommt
auch das immer noch ein Moment bei dem
man trotz aller Schwere des Moments
immer den Atem anhält muss man sagen
das natürlich auch tausendmal geprobt
im Hintergrund sehen wir
Rolf family stehen die Damen sind mit
dem Auto gekommen und der sagt der
jetzt hinein
[Musik]
er sagt der Queen der jetzt
hineingetragen wird in Westminster Hall
dieses
aus tausend Jahre alte traditionsreiche
Gebäude
[Musik]
mit langsamen Schritt
und hinten formiert man sich am Eingang
wir konnten beobachten wie Ihr Kind
Charles wie Prinz William ihre
Handschuhe auszogen ihre kappenabnahmen
hier geht man jetzt entlang
an den Enkelkindern Beatrice sehen wir
da so viel wessigs sehen wir im
Hintergrund
die Royal Family
ein Blick auf die prachtvolle Krone und
den wunderschönen weißen bluten Schmuck
dort auf dem Sack
[Musik]
und dort in dieser Stelle wird
der Sarg jetzt vier Tage lang bleiben
damit alle Abschied nehmen können ein
letztes goodbye für ihre Kunden
ein letzter Besuch
ein letztes dankeschön
[Musik]
ganz bewegende Momente hier bei Bild
live es ist die letzte Reise der Queen
durch London die große Prozession die
jetzt ein Ende gefunden hat dort in
Westminster Hall am Montag dann das
große Staatsbegräbnis jetzt aber erstmal
ist sie noch einmal Queen der Herzen für
alle Menschen die sich verabschieden
wollen
die letzte große Reise von Queen
Elizabeth der zweiten die große
Prozession durch London durch die
Hauptstadt und dieses reise seit diese
Reise hat soeben ein Ende gefunden
investmenster Hall jetzt haben die
Britinnen und Briten die Gelegenheit
sich von ihrer Queen zu verabschieden
wir wollen reden über diese historischen
Momente über diese emotionalen Momente
hier bei mir im Studio begrüße ich ganz
herzlich unsere bildshow-chefin Tanja
mai society-expertin Bettina von
Schimmelmann ist bei uns und auch Tilman
Billing sie sind Körpersprache Experte
und haben all denen die dort beteiligt
waren die natürlich gefangen waren in
diesem Protokoll aber ganz genau in die
Augen ins Gesicht auf den Körper
geschaut was glauben sie für wen war
dieser Moment dieser Gang heute die wir
gerade beobachten konnten der schwerste
also am ausschussreichsten war es
tatsächlich ins Gesicht von Harry zu
schauen
einerseits war er stolz jetzt doch
wieder Teil der Familie zu sein und man
hat es auch gesehen er war einerseits
sehr traurig aber er hat auch mal Freude
gesehen erst wieder dabei und der kann
jetzt auch seiner Oma das letzte letzte
Ehre erweisen also das war am
interessantesten ihn zu sehen zwischen
Trauer und auch Freude und Stolz wieder
dabei zu sein sobald man meinen Blick
auf Harry erhaschen konnte haben wir
alle ganz genau hingeschaut Bettina das
waren eine ganz besondere Stimmung eben
gerade etwas ich habe es gerade gesagt
dass wir so noch nie gesehen haben
historisch 70 Jahre saß sie auf dem
Thron welche Bilder welche Emotionen
haben dich jetzt eben gerade am meisten
gepackt die Symbolik natürlich an der
ganzen Sache dass eben erstmal die vier
Geschwister also die Kinder der Queen
hinter ihr laufen und dann natürlich
Harry und William zusammen auch wenn sie
eben der einen Uniform der andere nicht
den Uniform das trennte sie irgendwie
auch optisch aber trotzdem hatte ich das
Gefühl das machen sie jetzt erst alle
zusammen das wollen sie auch alle so
zusammen machen und der zweite Punkt
natürlich der Applaus wir haben nur
einmal kurz gehört ich habe aber gehört
dass der jetzt schon öfter stattfand in
den letzten paar Tagen ja dass man diese
diese Verbindung zwischen
den Londonern und ihrer Queen was ganz
besonderes und Tanja du bist auch
wirklich das merkt man totaler
herzensfan von der Queen von der Royal
Family da bist du wahrscheinlich
Optimistin wenn ich dich Frage glaubst
du dass die Trauer dass das
zusammenfinden aber jetzt auch die
vielen Gelegenheiten wieder miteinander
ins Gespräch zu kommen diese Familie vor
allem die beiden Brüder aber auch die
gesamte Familie auch Kate und Meghan
dass all diese Trauer diese Familie
jetzt wieder mehr einen wird
ich hoffe es natürlich Patricia aber ich
glaube es nicht ich glaube die
funktionieren jetzt natürlich in den
nächsten Tagen noch und vielleicht auch
noch in den nächsten Wochen aber Prinz
Harry hat ja schon angekündigt dass
seine Biografie die ja schon für im
Vorfeld für viel Wirbel sorgt gesorgt
hat die jetzt im Herbst erscheinen soll
dass er sie trotz des Todes seiner
Großmutter veröffentlichen wird und
natürlich blickt es Königshaus gespannt
darauf was ist dieses Mal wohl sein wird
was Harry da behauptet und was da wohl
wieder böses über die Königsfamilie
veröffentlicht wird und ich muss sagen
auch das bestätigt mich wieder darin
dass Prinz Harry und Meghan doch leider
sehr egoistisch sind und doch nur an
sich selbst denken an ihre eigene
Wirkung denken und nicht mal jetzt wo
die geliebte Großmutter die Geliebte
Königin gestorben ist der neue König im
Amt ist nicht mal jetzt treten sie einen
Schritt zurück also und da glaube ich
nicht dass es zu einem langen Frieden
kommen wird wenn man es ganz genau
anschauen in den kommenden Tagen da
haben wir noch allerlei Gelegenheiten um
da genau einen Blick drauf zu haben
vielen herzlichen Dank für euren für
ihren Besuch hier im Studio zu diesem
historischen Moment hier bei Bild live
danke
[Musik]